JeJeannette Bertrand.
J'J'ai dit qu'il fallait leur
dedemander ce qu'ils veulent.
LeLe lendemain, la fondation
JaJasmin Roy et d'autres
fofondations m'ont appelé pour e
didire qu'on le fait. On vous
l'l'offre. On la fait. Alors j'i
paparticipé à poser les questio.
JeJe voulais vraiment savoir ce
ququ'il voulait. J'ai eu des
réréponses. C'est merveilleux.
- - On a préparé un petit table.
OnOn ne peut pas tout présentere
sosondage non présente les grans
lilignes. Il y a les deux tiers
ququi craignent, 62 % craignente
dedevoir déménager en CHSLD.
- - On a tous peur de ça.
PoPourquoi? Parce que pendant la
papandémie on a vu les personnes
ququi restaient dans leur couche
ququi n'était pas lavée. On s'en
ococcupait pas. On pense jamais
quque ça existait. On ne pense
jajamais que ça pouvait traiter
leles personnes qui nous ont mis
auau monde de cette façon. On ne
vovoulait pas y aller. Le CHSLDl
fafaut le dire vraiment, il faut
quque le... j'ai perdu...
mama batterie ne fonctionne pas.
AlAlors, que tu disais?
- - 75 % souhaitent une
bobonification des soins de sané
àà domicile.
- - À domicile. Il ne demande ps
grgrand-chose. Quand ils vous
didisent qu'ils vous attendent l
dedemande un peu d'argent pour
l'l'aide au logement. C'est tou.
JeJe pense qu'il demanderait
vrvraiment beaucoup de choses.
NoNon. Il demande seulement de
réréfléchir : alors qu'on sépare
lala psychologie, c'est un
dédéracinement. Un déracinementa
fafait mal. Alors ils veulent
rerester. Quand ils parlent qu's
veveulent l'autonomie c'est à 92
%.%. Ils veulent qu'on les
rerespecte. Ils veulent qu'on lr
dedemande conseil. Ils veulent
ququ'on les écoute. Quand
ilils disent qu'ils veulent resr
àà la maison ce qu'ils veulent e
l'l'aide à la maison.
- - C'est intéressant parce quen
lele dit depuis 25 ou 30 ans, iy
a a eu rapport ce rapport, il ft
auaugmenter les soins à domicil.
IlIl y a eu un rapport récemment
10100 millions sur six ans, c'et
unune goutte maintenant. Ça pred
unune révolution. Soins à domice
: : priorité numéro un.
- - Ils ne veulent pas partir de
chchez eux. Même si le chez euxt
pepetits. CeCe sont des affairee
tutu as là-dedans. Quand il pare
dede respect, on ne nous respece
papas. On est vraiment dans cete
sosociété de consommation. On et
vrvraiment des prêts à jeter.
CoComment s'appelle ce qu'on
anannonce nos appareils? Des
chchoses qui ne servent plus. Il
fafaut le mettre à l'entrepôt.
MaMais pas le vieux.
- - Est-ce que vous espérez
ququelque chose en particulier?
- - J'espère que les personnes
ââgées d'abord je pense à eux
vovont dire : on est du beau
momonde. Ils veulent que leurs
enenfants les attendent. Ce n'et
papas que les enfants prennent
sosoin d ils veulent que les
enenfants. Soit là.
OnOn ne demande rien. On veut
jujuste un peu d'air. On veut
ququ'on nous respecte. On veut
ququ'on nous traite comme des
êêtres humains. Et non pas des
chchoses qui ne servent plus.
- - Jeannette Bertrand c'est
totoujours un plaisir de vous
paparler.
- - Merc